Steve Jobs is one of the most polarizing
figures in tech as admired for his
genius as he was derided for his hubris
but regardless of how you feel about him
the new biopic about the apple founder
will make you like him or at least
respect him the time article said your
Apple stock was worth 441 million
dollars no I feel like Apple stock has
been dramatically undervalued the new
film written by aaron sorkin and
directed by Slumdog Millionaire danny
boyle tells the story of jobs his life
through three distinct product launch
events the first is the launch of the
Macintosh in 1984 the second the launch
of the next cube in 1988 and finally the
launch of the imac in 1998 it's not so
much a story told in three acts as it is
a story told in two big setbacks and one
huge win all of them happening in the
bowels of auditoriums sound boring it's
surprisingly not dressing rooms have
never seemed so electric and Michael
Fassbender's jobs and Kate Winslet as
Apple's marketing head Joanna Hoffman
are exceptionally on point and even when
Jobs is berating his staff or trying
feebly to relate to his young daughter
he's extremely watchable it's having no
control thank you aaron sorkin for that
Sorkin started as a playwright so he's
very comfortable writing for people in
tight quarters is insane you slept with
twenty eight percent of American men i
was using an algorithm if there's one
person who can make the launch of a
personal computer more interesting than
Steve Jobs it's him and like he did with
facebook on the social network Sorkin is
here to make tech as high drama as a
heart attack but if that drama true the
film is technically an adaptation of
Walter Isaacson's biography of jobs but
not everything that happens in Steve
Jobs happen to to Steve Jobs that's okay
the apple founder was mythologized even
while he was alive and that mythology
has only
since his passing in 2011 what did you
do I play the orchestra this is evident
in the fact that there have been nearly
a dozen movies and documentaries made
about jobs this latest is the third to
come out just this year but it's safe to
say Hollywood sig the best the last